[Applause]
there's an american super brand that's
now in over 800 uk locations and
counting
it takes 48 million orders a year in the
uk
processing two every second we'll
produce 75 million dough balls a year
just out of this one facility but it's a
company
trying to compete in a 30 billion pound
uk takeaway market
that's reaching saturation point we have
to go to space to do it
by golly we'll go to space
so it takes a special kind of dedication
to succeed
this isn't just a job for me or a
livelihood this is life
in its 30th anniversary year
domino's pizza opens its doors to
cameras for the very first time
you know what we are not insurance
salesmen we are domino's pizza people
love us
and we meet the workers willing to go to
extraordinary lengths
to deliver food to your door on time i
never did mistake
oh my god in a company where it's
possible to succeed
if you live and breathe the brand it's
doing well for myself and my family
and for some it's a life commitment if i
hadn't found a job
in domino's i probably would have either
been in jail or i would have been dead
and that is a [ __ ] up
[Applause]
welcome to the world of dominoes
[Music]
domino's first arrived on our shores in
1985.
now it's the uk's largest pizza delivery
company
instilling its workforce with an almost
religious fervor
somebody may look at us you know kind of
say yeah is that kind of a cult group
but we're not
what we are is we're a little bit out
there we're a little bit
[Applause]
when you're in that crazy and you've got
like 2 000 people all champed in the
same thing
it will give you goosebumps on and you
do join in with over 800 branches across
the nation
large texas barbecue and a large
meatloaf has extra cheese guys
the company has an army of over 25 000
team members
chicken pineapple and sweet corn please
the most dedicated of whom
are known as dominoids a domino yeah
it's basically somebody that bleeds
sauce and spit cheese they think
domino's pizza
when they go home they think domino's
pizza when they wake up
if you don't have that mindset probably
not a dominoid
[Music]
27 year old matt taylor is a store
manager from south wales
there's a lot of drawbacks from working
in a tasty pizza place um
since i started working in domino's just
over eight years ago and i've brought
just under 10 and a half stone
and that is no lies that is genuine i'm
full on pizzeria
yeah i i was addicted to pizza for so
long i'm not sick of eating them now i
could eat i could eat one right now
[Music]
as well as being a full-on pizza eater
he's also a self-confessed dominoid
my funeral i want to be cremated so the
song i want as i'm going into the little
death chamber
i went um the dominoes chant well wait
tomorrow's pizza i want that on the go
um and when domino's flag draped over
that's how i want to go out man in style
and it isn't just the brand that matt
has a passion for
he recently tied the knot with his area
manager emma
[Music]
at a company convention in las vegas
we met um the first week we started
training here
i asked her out when he was drunk when i
was drunk
have you got anything else to add to a
lovely relationship no
matt and emma want to take their
relationship to its natural next step
by buying their own store we complement
each other in what we can do and
therefore
by owning a store we can play to each
other's strengths
you do know you won't be my boss then we
would be equals
yeah excellent
with 240 tons of cheese and 124 tonnes
of tomato sauce passing through their
stores each week
speed is the difference between profit
and loss
in colchester there's a training camp
that takes this efficiency to an extreme
level
stop stretch pick it up and flip yeah
that's it
shane just be careful what you're doing
there yeah cause you're not picking up
the eastern regional team are a crack
squad of pizza makers
so shane do it again for me i said yeah
so again who are practicing their skills
for the domino's equivalent of the world
cup
that's it the fastest pizza making
championships
and go go go cheese no cheese and
mushrooms mushrooms mushrooms nice skin
lovely pizza
the aim of the competition is to make
three high-quality pizzas as quickly as
possible
the sauce this time yeah easy on the
sauce i picked twelve wipe and twelve
easy one four mushrooms at five o'clock
almost is it five o'clock time
[Music]
good one good pepperoni ready set pick
it nice skin lovely pizza
head coach kieran worked for the company
in india moved here in 2006
and is now the uk's fourth fastest pizza
maker
lots of people know the technique they
know they have the speed they have the
skill
but it's about on the main stage as well
they need to hold their nerves
and go cheers now wipe it well wipe it
well that's good probably watch it
for competitors who can't hold their
nerve there is the ultimate fear
i'm just having a little bit of an issue
with the pepperoni at the moment which
i'm hoping to rectify shortly
the dreaded pepperoni shakes
shaky hands mean they can't place the
pepperoni properly
and risk disqualification when you try
to pull it off from your hands it
doesn't come
so if you take three four or five six
pepperoni so easy to spread
okay for the next six weeks these
regional training camps will be vital
if anyone from the team is to stand a
chance against their fiercest rival
26 year old store manager zagros jaff
[Music]
at 16 he left a war-torn iraq and moved
to the uk
first when i arrived in this country i
initially didn't have any clue about the
pizza
i never eat it i never seen any before i
didn't know how to make it
anything like that a year after arriving
here
he stretched his first pizza
and just three years after that he was
crowned the fastest pizza maker in the
country
[Music]
just recently we had our first baby
and i wanna do everything i can
to make sure he's proud in the future as
well
but zagross now has a serious technical
problem that could thwart his ambitions
we've been called out today because if
one of the guys here has broken his
spoon
i have no idea what a spoodle is but i'm
quite sure once we uh investigate it and
have a look we can see if we can fix it
for him
every pizza maker in the company uses a
specialist piece of equipment to add
sauce to their dough
so with the saucing on the spoodle
you've got to make sure that you have a
nice
clean even coverage all the way around
it's known as a spoodle
a cross between a spoon and a ladle
thank you very much forgot today i have
won the last three years the uk fastest
pizza maker with this puddle
let's have a look okay look i can't
guarantee anything but i'm quite happy
to give it a go for you
this buddha i could compare as a third
arm for me
without this i probably won't be able to
do it we've welded both sides for you
i don't want to grind too much of the
weld off because it affects strength
the fixed spoodle's first test will be
the fastest pizza making heats in three
weeks time
if he wins it would be nice to share
some of the prize money as we've
contributed to fixing his tour
[Laughter]
[Music]
bringing the fastest pizza making
competition to britain
was the brainchild of american import
and uk operations director
scott macleod fast on her feet not on
the street
scott started out delivering pizzas in
college and worked his way to senior
management
by living the dominoid philosophy our
company
is all about energy
enthusiasm kind of pushing it you know
to go to that next level
first gear doesn't work second you've
got to get to that fourth and fifth gear
before you really qualify as a domino
scott is now trying to bring the
american dream to over 800 uk branches
slice by slice good morning everybody
and today he's holding a meeting at
milton keynes headquarters
to discuss the company's answer to the
oscars you all ready to get started on
this
the domino's awards so what we'll do is
go through each one of these candidates
and let's talk about what makes them
special what makes them elite the most
prestigious award
is for manager of the year so first one
candidate a
this person clearly just lives the brand
they've actually married someone um
within domino's
at a las vegas rally candidate a is
dominoid matt
from clinically yeah the manager of the
euro one is something i absolutely want
and i won't quit until i got it
four large pizzas and two cookies yeah
but that is something i will get
not when it will i will get it pizzas
are coming out perfect
keep it up so candid b um
again oer average of five star is
delivered those sales numbers
that service performance but also
improve profit
candidate b is pizza ninja zagros from
portsmouth
i've done everything i can for last 12
months to become a
manager of the year i think there is a
lot more icon
in dominoes these people deserve it you
know and
the there is always there's only can
only be one winner and that's the
hardest thing to do
back in clenethley store manager matt is
only too aware that head office will be
paying close attention to his sales
figures tonight
jones it's a big night rugby's on
uh wales are playing our fierce rivals
which are england
and hopefully we smash the granny over
them
with a town full of fans this is set to
be the store's busiest night of the year
[Music]
alright guys tonight is a big night it's
going to be very very busy
certain i was not straight away certain
i was right when i was younger things
are really bad i grew up in foster care
i was bringing foster care at the age of
eight years old
ben you're on slap in gemma's gonna be
next to you if then peter's not good
enough mid she's chucking them back to
you you sort them out you get them good
enough right
i've pretty much failed everything i've
done in life rhys you're next to gemma
i want to see big things from your items
abdominals was a crunch time for me like
whoa this is like
this is a real job you know i mean anna
and you're on the end you only put
things in the oven nobody else okay
they took me on they give me a chance
okay excellent thank you guys cheers
[Music]
at peak times large stores can churn out
seven pizzas a minute come on it's
getting the oven straight away
and seventy thousand pizzas an hour
across the company
guys cover garlic dip in there please
straight away yeah it's getting really
busy now we've got two full screens on
the make leg
in order to be named manager of the year
matt must hit strict quality targets
but with all 15 drivers on the road
piled-up pizzas are in danger of going
cold
we're looking on our screen don't look
at the screen because it's kind of red
an order turning red means the delivery
is late yeah i need a lot of drivers
[Music]
quick
every domino's store worldwide tries to
get the pizza out of the door within 10
minutes
and delivered within 30 minutes of an
order being placed
you can fall behind very easy it takes
seconds seconds and you're back to
square one
at his clinically store manager of the
year nominee matt taylor
is having his busiest night of the year
we've got a full board of deliveries
coming out
so it's getting really busy at the
moment but with all of his drivers on
the road
pizzas aren't being delivered in time
yeah orders are stacking up now
finally a driver returns
[Music]
but he's been unable to find the
delivery address check his map
always check him out um i don't like
doing double baggers on deliveries but
sometimes we have to
i can't mess this up i need to make sure
these deliveries go right
delivering two orders at the same time
can affect the pizza's temperature on
arrival come on boys just get these out
luke get two on a case for him right
back him up you've got to be in the same
area
but when it gets really busy it's the
only option
yeah i'll get in there slowly taking
chunks out
want that one then that one then that
one and then you move down to these
right
matt's strategy seems to be paying off
and there's good news for the team all
right guys i want to congratulate you
all you've just smashed a record hour
so i want to clap for everybody
absolutely
smash that we had zero complaints
zero that's not that's under one
keep it up guys that was awesome
uh the record we smashed was um sales in
one hour i mean
obliterate today ripped it into one
tucked it under
nice for bed so long cheerio have a good
one
gone absolutely gone
[Music]
the company's hq is in milton keynes
where every pizza is born
since opening in 1985 the company has
made enough pizzas in the uk
to stretch around the world 20 times
and this factory produces nine tons of
dough an hour
[Music]
pepperoni passion is the most popular of
the 18 pizzas on the current menu
but the company's answer to willy wonka
development manager emilia parker
has the job of creating the next
gastronomic hit
onions tomatoes chicken so we're about
to
launch a new exciting pizza great
tasting pizza hopefully
um well not hopefully we know it's great
tasting
what do you think of this do you think
the bhaji bits look okay
yeah they're much better do you think
there's enough on there yeah weight wise
definitely
her latest creation is the new chicken
tikka pizza
a hybrid of two of the nation's favorite
takeaways and the result
of 18 months of development people will
be very surprised
at the amount that we have to think
about to create a pizza
you know i could just quickly make
something up and put a couple of
mushrooms on it
but do you ever have a chicken tikka
with mushrooms in it probably not
it looks great it's going to be marketed
brilliantly
so i'm pretty confident about it
[Music]
the tikka pizza ingredients will now be
shipped out for a test run in stores
around the country
[Music]
every domino store runs as an individual
franchise
allowing each of its owners known as
franchisees to use its trademark
and sell its products technically anyone
can become a franchisee
provided they can raise two hundred and
eighty thousand pounds to buy their own
store that is
i dream to be a franchisee i've been
saving and i'm looking up towards about
two years time
i shouldn't be getting there the
american dream of domino's pizza
you know that it lives and breezes you
can start off at any level
and grow within the company
[Music]
is one of the company's most successful
franchisees and at the age of 32
owns nine stores
some franchisees own over 100 stores and
have done very well for themselves
could anyone become a millionaire at
domino's look i've i've done well so i
can't complain
um and i believe i believe in people so
i'd have to say yes
eddie was 16 years old when he began as
a driver
when i started it was on a 50cc moped
which was an automatic they don't make
them anymore
the ones that we used to use for
delivery
but just four years later he convinced
his parents to remortgage their house to
buy him his first store
being a domino's pizza franchisee
you know there's great perks you can
hire whoever you want so i hired
one of the most sexiest you know pas so
this is uh
my personal assistant and i married her
and i'm only joking
so this is my wife
you can't build a company you can't
build you know a viable business
if people don't have integrity you know
so
you know this is you know it's not
number one it's not number two it's not
number three
it's definitely number one and
everything kind of starts from there
eddie is about to open his 10th branch
[Applause]
so welcome to our quarterly meeting
obviously everyone knows we've got the
new park gate store opening up
you know we're mega excited about that
[Applause]
you hear stories you know from rags to
riches and
and i think they're important because it
kind of gives you know people belief
that it is possible and
you know i'm definitely one of them
stories
in the gladiatorial arena of milton
keynes there's another group of
dominoids
looking for their moment in the
spotlight very good morning to you all
and welcome to england's fastest pizza
maker
2015 heat
today pizza athletes from across the
country have gathered to compete for a
place in the grand finals
i'll be judging um your docking your
stretching your placement
and then your sourcing and then it'll
pass over to simon
who's gonna monitor your cheesing
portioning and itemizing
okay there's real prestige to winning
this competition
and naturally the guys want to go out of
here with a head's held high
for the competition winner there is a
500 pound prize up for grabs
ready set begin begin begin and entry
into the european championships
here spread your mushrooms
this is what we want we want the energy
we want excitement we want everything
these guys are given
next up it's reigning uk champion and
manager of the year candidate zagros
jaff
and even he is feeling the pressure of
the big occasion for our current uk iron
champion
everything is possible i mean we're
talking about a second
anyone could go through a smallest
mistake it could
knock me out in a competition basically
[Music]
you spread the mushrooms
please cheese
[Applause]
good job well done well done
very very good
look at that guys now it's heating up 54
seconds
fantastic putting all the effort to
fixing that squirtle is definitely paid
off
um had a good round hopefully um i'll go
through to final
zagros has taken a commanding lead but
the day is far from over
zagross's closest rivals are all from
the eastern regional elite team
we take it very seriously it's something
that we're all very passionate about
[Music]
we don't have a competition we want to
win
i think there's every chance that zagros
could be knocked out today and that's
what we're going to go for
[Music]
40 new domino's stores opened across the
uk last year
and franchisee eddie has recently
purchased his 10th branch in rotherham
and in just two days time it's his grand
opening
[Music]
hello hey taz
how's the hiring and new staff members
getting
taz on arrived in the uk from pakistan
on a university scholarship
when he was 20 years old
i don't mind then they call me like
tasmanian devils
like sometimes you have to be serious
with like and sometimes with mood like
love
joke he started as a part-time driver
worked his way up the company and now
london-based eddie is trusting taz to
manage his new yorkshire store
it's quite a lot of pressure on me
because obviously it's grand opening
and as we're doing first time in this
company
every year the company's drivers travel
over 13 million miles across the uk
hi mr zen hi my name is taz how are you
today are you good yeah
great have a lovely day and taz needs to
employ a team of 16
willing to drive the extra mile for his
big night sorry how are you
my dream is a businessman
so hopefully in 2016
i will be as a franchisee dominoes
[Music]
taz hopes to find drivers with the same
dedication to the company as himself
my worst thing in domino's was a busy
night saturday i was in work
and my partner she was in hospital and
she gave birth
to my daughter so i missed that time
because of that busy night i was still
in shock
[Music]
do you have full uk driving yes i have a
full uk
i need points on it yes i have a few how
many points
but it's not just taz feeling the strain
in the kitchen 23 year old assistant
manager hannah is having a nightmare
[Music]
with a side order of disaster the oven
is packaging all together um i don't
know what's happened
it's just decided to quit on us the day
before the grand opening
i don't eat pizza now i don't like pizza
i like making it i just don't like
eating it obviously we've got this like
um 100 free pizzas giveaway and then
all these offers on top of that we need
the oven
i am a bit nervous yeah 85
000 pizzas are expected to be baked on
this conveyor belt every year
but at this rate they'll be zero pizzas
for the grand opening just 24 hours away
oh my god
back in the milton keynes competition
room kieran's team and his full
entourage
are about to compete in the fastest
pizza making championship eats
their aim is to knock lone ranger zagros
out of the competition
there's a lot of great people here where
they got potential to win the
competition basically
[Music]
hoping to cause the upset abali zubi
amman
and seasoned veteran kieran
everyone wants to be a champion you know
ready set begin
for me it's my whole life
he's going to be he's going to do this
[Applause]
but has kieran's team done enough to
knock zagros out
and this is how close it is to top two
karen with a phenomenal time of 54-22
5403 manager of the year nominee zagross
has held on to his top spot by
milliseconds
and he will now face kieran in the grand
finals in birmingham
i salute all of you and if that's what
you do on a tuesday friday saturday
night in our stores
phenomenal phenomenal job well done
it's the day of the grand opening of the
brand new store in rotherham
now it says reset again and the oven
still isn't working
at this moment in time we can't do any
orders unfortunately
and there's an extra topping of pressure
because franchisee eddie lamarr
is on route with his area manager rimpal
and danny
the domino's mascot i'm mega excited
this is the biggest launch we've ever
had
[Music]
but with eddie just minutes away
[Music]
hannah and taz have a breakthrough
i fixed it i fixed it
the big bosses are here so it's good
it's just going to be you know super
exciting we just want to make sure that
we can
handle the volume coming in you know
we've got someone now just
doing a bit of tidying up cleaning up
just making sure that everything's uh
you know gonna be ready for the day the
grand opening is a chance for taz to
prove himself to the boss
fridge needs to be full up yeah all
right clean up all around here all the
dust all in letters and stuff like that
tells me we want everything spotless
yeah but no small detail gets past eddie
eagle eyes
why is this like this because this is
inside you need to you need to
find a way it's not like they're going
to be queueing for one minute they're
going to get their pizza and they're
going to go
and they're they're not going to close
their eyes they're going to be looking
around and they're going to see all this
stuff
it needs to be spotless do you know what
i mean
domino's sells over 76 million pizzas a
year in the uk
[Music]
gets through enough tomato sauce to fill
two olympic swimming pools
and slices 800 tons of pepperoni the
equivalent
of 80 double-decker london buses
the company opens an average of four new
stores a month
and in rotherham balloons and the
balloon pump we did have it it's just an
hour until the grand opening
of franchisee eddie's 10th store
anything that shouldn't be in its place
that pen there i don't know if that
should be there
but nothing needs to be where it
shouldn't be
today's the big day this is what we've
been working up to so
this is when you know it's really
happening yeah that's perfect
just keep an eye on it because that's
fresh though yeah okay
be a franchisee it does look stressful
but you need the brains for that as well
so what we want to do ted
is we want to have aces in places right
so you need to make a decision
who you're going to have where and stop
write down aces and places
and write down game plan yeah
the store opening is eddie's chance to
win over new customers from his local
competitors
and he's looking for big profits to
justify his six-figure investment right
great stuff guys
let's crack on let's smile let's be
happy let's enjoy the rest of the day
let's go
[Applause]
the first hundred customers to arrive
get a free pizza
and the mayor and maeres of rotherham
are guests of honor
welcome to domino's so mr mayor what's
your favorite topping i think
uh i think for today i think uh ham and
cheese
but before anyone goes inside eddie
wants to treat them to a bit of dominoid
culture
hi guys customers if you don't have a
look at me just for two secs
we're gonna teach you the domino's chant
so i'm gonna say
who are we and then everyone's gonna say
domino's pizza
then i'm gonna say what are we
and then you're gonna say number one so
everyone ready
yay everyone ready
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
great sorry my fault my fault i should
have mentioned it it's three times at
the end
are you ready thank you for the
invitation
and to declare this domino pizzas open
[Music]
the new chicken tikka pizza ingredients
have traveled 190 miles
from milton kings hq to south wales and
matt taylor
will be one of the first to trial them
in his branch here is lads
devil's door
right there lads here it is
tikka saw some bhaji bites
[Laughter]
hundreds of thousands of pounds are
spent on the launch of each new pizza
design
so specialist training is required to
ensure perfection
making sure individual stores keep up
standards is the job of excellence
manager
and fully paid up dominoid felicity
smith
you know what we are not insurance
salesmen we are domino's pizza people
love us
you guys have got your aprons on hand
washed ready for action
beautiful oh that smells like sunshine
so it really is round the outside first
and then do your middle
go with the team up to speed on the
tikka technicalities
it's now the bit they've been looking
forward to have a really good try of it
i'm going to ask you some questions
afterwards um yeah sources i would stand
there
it
the team now want to generate a buzz
among potential customers
so attempt to spice up the lives of
clinthley residents
[Music]
free pizza
[Music]
yeah in rotherham there's a catchment
area of 40 000 potential new customers
for eddie's new store
anyone waiting to be saved and although
his grand opening is in full swing
on a level of one to five we're being
stressed i'm about five
eddie needs to spread the word further
all right
franchisees do their own local marketing
to drum up business
and eddie has a cunning strategy
matt would you like to join a raffle
it's to win one of three prizes
what a beautiful mascot i mean i love
him
judge join the raffle you know he's got
such a beautiful smile on
on his face all right mate would like to
join a raffle you really can't put a
price on that
pizza dominos it's a tough gig for 16
year olds josh and jacob
if i didn't earn a job at my age then i
wouldn't i'd still be lazy enough i
wouldn't ever get a job so i thought
it's the best thing to do
i think it's just hard to get work in
general to be honest like
a lot of people haven't got jobs at my
age
they're always skinned and i've always
got morning pretty much trying to join
free raffle mate
that guy at the left was at a party with
me yesterday
but the local boys have a problem
[Music]
they're wearing the wrong colors
[Music]
everyone started to think with middle
wall so we best get out of here
quick as possible
let's go now
[Music]
it's a big day for manager of the year
nominee matt
i walked into one of the stores the
other day uh and one of the boys there
was telling me abdominals it's not very
good company it's just a pizza
and it's not even a real job anyway and
i absolutely
blew my lid dominoes means hell of a lot
it means more to me than what it would
mean to most people
this isn't just a job for me or a
livelihood this is life
he's got a trial promotion as a store
auditor which could put him one step
closer to his dream
of becoming a franchisee let's do this
people are not tenderly happy to see me
because they don't really like get in
store with it
today he's making a surprise inspection
of a local branch
hello my darling to make sure they
measure up to head office's standards
all right dal so i'm just going to get
on with what i have to
yeah um and then i'll give you a shout
out and finish at the end then
go through feedback and stuff right
which is part
i went completely off the royals as a
kid i mean
drinking i used to fight all the time
doing all sorts of things
so that is that your personal money is
it right okay
if i hadn't found a job um in domino's i
probably would have either been in jail
or i would have been dead and that is a
fact in my opinion
so go through some points right the
driver's side man he needs to
change his trousers frank's hot dip a
bottle just
give the top a wipe right these are the
standards that we expect
um if these drop we're going to lose
points if that's it
[Music]
domino's has saved me the way i was
going
i never thought one day i'd have a wife
and i'd own my own house not in a
million years
[Applause]
[Music]
in rotherham it's been 10 hours since
the opening of the store
chicken pineapple and sweet corn it's on
screen top order the screen is top
franchisee eddie has headed back to
london leaving taz and his team alone
to deal with the dinner time rush 205
is ready 70 of domino's customers have
their orders delivered to their homes
so a shortage of drivers at his branch
means pizzas are piling up delivery is
about i've got about 20 25 deliveries on
screen so
and taz just can't afford to make a bad
impression and lose a single customer to
his
rivals almost driver everyone is on road
so
maybe i have to jump on road
helping out with deliveries is taz's
only option but it means leaving his
store without a manager
in rotherham unemployment is almost
eleven percent yet taz still hasn't been
able to fill all his driver positions
see the most people here they just
rely on benefits the benefit is the kind
of you can say it's free money
so why you should don't go and just work
because
they are perfect god make perfect they
have
working everything hands arms legs
feeds eyes
his team could process 400 pizzas an
hour
so the quicker taz can make the
deliveries
the quicker he can get back to managing
his store thank you
thanks a lot thank you enjoy your meal
oh yeah sorry
what what order number is it what is it
oh no this is not your order story i'll
be back in five minutes love
i never did mistake oh my god
i'm not perfect hundred person but i'm
trying my best
to keep my customer my employees happy
you wanted that one what as well
yeah i can they give you that one as
well if you wanted to stop it
sorry so yeah sorry thanks a lot thank
you
[Music]
i work for my bottom of heart because i
make pizzas i make pizza like how i make
for myself how
i make for my brother my mom i make for
customer the same pieces
and this sort of dedication will be
needed to put eddie's new store
on the rotherham map it gets exciting
because it's not the same every day
it's always different that's what i like
about this show
there's always some challenge along the
way
[Music]
dominoes sell 1.4 million pizzas every
week
and the uk's appetite for takeaway food
shows no sign of slowing down
today it's the most important event on
any dominoids calendar
thousands of their employees have
descended on birmingham to attend the
annual rally and awards ceremony
proceedings kick off with the final of
the uk's fastest pizza making
competition
are you guys ready i love it i love it
26 year old reigning champion zagross is
going head-to-head
against seasoned veteran kieran backed
by his huge support team
you know that is the movement kieran
padilla if something goes wrong
you have to wait under the ear our
current
uk and ireland champion are definitely
dreaming to be
a world champion
all my focus will be literally on that
trailer though
everything else is out of my head you
only one man can be crowned victorious
and gain the opportunity of further
glory
in the european and world championships
[Music]
timers are you ready judges are you
ready
ready participants are you ready
ready ready set begin
what's up
[Applause]
[Applause]
please
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's gone to the wire and we're both
finalists convinced they have won
it's now in the hands of the judges to
make the split decision
let's wait for the official time
has zagross retained his title or has
kieran won it back for his team
let's have a look guys we need to now
confirm find out
all right the 2015
winner for the uk and ireland
fastest pizza maker is
that close with a new personal best of
48 seconds flat
zagross has taken the trophy and the 500
pound prize money
[Applause]
i'm feeling great to be honest with you
i mean i can't describe it all right to
win the
fourth year and back to back but i'm
really happy
very happy done something like this it's
not disappointing you know it's
it's a learning you know so definitely
we're gonna try work hard for next year
and we will try to
get that it's been a dramatic final
but there are bigger things to come
someone will be taking home the
prestigious manager of the year award
at the evening ceremony
[Music]
police open up are you ready you are
emma's having a
nightmare tonight uh the hair hasn't
gone right then i've had to blame fred
again
oh my god i don't know i'm not a
hairdresser
it's something i would look to maybe do
a college course on if you fancier
27 year old matt is one of the managers
in the running for this year's title
if i did win manager you'd mean hell of
a lot because to come from
like thousands and thousands of other
people from nothing but to actually go
that extra mile and make something on
myself
it'd mean it'd mean a lot to me
personally right we ready rock
yeah let's get the show on the road here
let's go win some awards
[Music]
but matt has stiff competition in the
form of the recently crowned fastest
pizza maker zagross
it's not about trying to win something
i'm just doing my job basically properly
the manager of the year award is the
defining moment of the domino's calendar
it's between the uk's fastest pizza
maker
and the man who lives and breathes the
brand many of our manager of the years
have gone on to become franchisees
themselves
but it is it is the epitome of the
awards for all of our people in our
stores
i've done everything i can for last 12
months to become a
manager of the year plus
a fast pizza maker if i hadn't found a
job
into home and those things would have
turned out really bad dominoes have made
me where i am today
taking the prize home this year is
domino's poster boy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been working really hard obviously
success
can not be made without the group of
people behind the
champion thank you
i've been waiting for this moment for
last 12 months
work really hard day in day out i'm
already thinking about what i'm going to
pick up
next at this time um when the next ride
is coming up
you know i'm happy for the guy you
wanted he made three pizzas in 48
seconds so you know
geez you don't do that too often but i'm
happy for the guy who won it
um so i'm guessing you'll have to clap
me when i win the next year
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you